[Music]
first crushes we all remember them and
if you're a girl who grew up in the 90s
your first crush might have been one of
the dream phone guys boy I think Gary he
has kind of a nice smile yeah I think
that's probably a jock this is my gray
the unlikely inventor of the ultimate
90s tween dating game we needed a game
targeted towards nine-year-old girls it
was a bunch of guys that did it but
that's okay I said let's do something
that's kind of like clue
so it's deduction we're going to call a
bunch of boys because we heard some boy
likes us so it all started with the
phone right yes we kind of laughed and
we kind of called this the pink slipper
you know in its day it was an elegant
and beautiful thing I know where he
hangs out so how did they pick the voice
of your teenage dreams we went to a
photo house we didn't know like who
these boys were anything we just picked
ones that we liked but that's not the
only 90s girls game Mike made he also
made the super successful mall madness
but he's pretty real about his influence
as a guy well if I'm going to make a
game about shopping what I know about
shopping you just go get what you need
and get back to the car later it was
pointed out to me that that's kind of
not the way ladies shop so it was kind
of in a funny way a guy's game you know
but it was for girls
I say games are together this in a box
play a game with people you learn a lot
about them and it shouldn't be about
winning and losing it should be about
being together
[Music]
without abraham lincoln and really his
beard Milton Bradley the godfather of
board games would have never existed
bold statement I know but let me explain
[Music]
the game of life the spinner the cars
the choices college or career kids or no
kids lawyer or farmer this family game
night staple was once a pretty morbid
game back in the 1800s Milton Bradley
was in the lithograph business following
the Republican National Convention of
1860 Bradley printed thousands of images
of Abraham Lincoln who was clean-shaven
at the time shortly thereafter Lincoln
debuted his iconic beard rendering all
of Bradley's prints worthless his lift
the graph business went belly-up
so Bradley was forced to try something
new he came up with a board game
seemingly dark and twisted board game
appropriately named the checkered game
of life the game functioned in a similar
way to how it does now
there was a spinner colored circles that
moved around the board and of course
squares that could either make you or
break you the squares on the original
game were overwhelmingly grim boasting
actions like disgrace poverty ruin crime
prison and well suicide regardless the
game flew off the shelf kids loved it
and Milton Bradley went on to own family
game night fast forward to about a
hundred years later they revamped the
game trading Bradley's morbid squares
for the more delightful ones like pay
day or graduation which we have all come
to know and love and so there you have
it the story of the game called life
thanks Lincoln
in many parts of the world scrabble is
viewed as the pastime as a game where
the old people play after retirement and
all that but Scrabble in Nigerian is
actually very big project it is seen at
the spot there is an actual National
Scrabble Federation under the Ministry
of sports they have a lot of young
people hoping to gain an actual living
from playing Scrabble
my name is Wellington G Gary and I'm the
word Scrabble champion absolute means
travel in 1996 when my immediate elder
brother taught me the game they told it
until six years after that I was playing
with some of my neighborhood friends and
they were like ah you are quite good why
not play in tournaments and I was like
wow you mediate ladies in tournaments
and vs. is trillions to say having an
African mean the word Scrabble
championship is bigger than I can
actually comprehend you needed to have
been in the hole to see the jubilation
of our other African brothers it was
something that everyone in Africa that
play Scrabble actually looked forward to
Nigeria is a very very diverse nation we
have well over 500 developed languages
for the major means of communication all
over Nigeria is English and since
Scrabble is based upon the English
vocabulary is going to be a way of
helping each and everyone improve the
command of the English language other
things will clear up there if I hadn't
played Scrabble men have been involved
in some other not so legitimate
activities and I think playing Scrabble
it keeps you on the right track
ok we are not blank to the fact that the
level of unemployment in the country is
very very image so I came up with the
wellington foundation for Scrabble and
mine development in Africa there's a lot
of similarities between how life
actually goes and how Scrabble goes you
get to understand that is not all the
time that you get things your way you
they have to make the best out of the
little that you are given you know each
country is known for a particular sport
Brazil for example is known for football
we are hoping to make trouble in
Nigerian sports about if you mention
trouble in any part of the world
Nigeria should come to mind Settlers of
Catan is one of the best-selling board
games of all time and nestled in the
rolling hills of Rostov Germany on this
picturesque Street pass the buzzer in
building 43 and standing in the back of
the garden is Klaus Teuber the man who
made it all happen Settlers of Catan is
a board game for up to four players
where you collect resources to build
settlements and cities there were points
first to ten wins and it all started
like this in the 90s and 80s I let a
dental laboratory developing games was a
little bit refuge for me
his first game was called Barbarossa
when I made Barbarossa I was in my early
thirties I feel that this is a kind of
thing I like very much developing games
and it could be in the future for me a
very very good hobby he designed a
handful of other games and then made
Catan Klaus had become interested in
Viking tales yes the story of the
Vikings inspired me I imagine how they
reach Iceland they need to would they
need houses and other things that's all
honest imagination idea of cartography
from design to market it was a family
affair this is Benny tuber he lives in
Germany and he is Klaus as youngest son
and this is jido tuber and this is gido
tuber he lives in San Francisco
he is Clauses eldest son in my family I
am one of the game testers along with my
mom
me too we played tested those had lots
of catan quite often we would all get
together at the dining room table and
would test and has his game sometimes we
put a Mickey Mouse comic next to my
chair so in case the game was boring he
knew that I would read it instead of
playing the game my dad took that and
tweaked that worked on it this was sort
of an exciting moment for my dad in the
tuber family there's a bit of
competition
my father would probably say I'm the
best player no sorry dad
Benny is bet hmm there's a bit of a
rivalry between my dad my brother Peter
Catan was officially released in Germany
in 1994 and it was an immediate success
we had an immediate success in Germany
because we won came up to you worldwide
to date over 24 million copies have been
sold this game was born out of a story
but it also creates stories
the beauty of Catan is that in the end
you still have constructed something so
in a way everybody went it was my wish
to have a very peaceful game with a lot
of interaction bringing people together
for me k'tano the success
[Music]
- all the Catan fans out there here's
some advice well you always have to
follow your strategy but also you have
to complain quite a bit even though you
know you're winning this we'll have to
say you're not a lot of building cities
as early as possible in the game never
built the longest road at the beginning
and there you have it
you